[Musik]
hallo und guten abend bei die richtigen
fragen bei bild tv ich begrüße jetzt im
studio bei uns live zu gast die
bundesinnenministerium nennt sie feser
vor vielen dank dass sie da sind guten
abend guten abend frau hesse wir leben
ja ein stück weit in seltsamen zeiten
ich weiß nicht wie genau sie den fall
verfolgt haben aber erst in den letzten
wochen gab es eine versteigerung in
berlin und da hat ein
wurde eine villa eines clan-chefs
versteigert von arafat abou chaker die
ihn gemeinsam mit dem rapper bushido
gehört hat und wissen sie wir
zugegriffen hat ja ich habe es gehört
natürlich und das ist ein themenbereich
der mich gerade sehr beschäftigt nämlich
die konsequente bekämpfung von
kleinkriminalität und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass es uns jetzt in der neuen
koalition gelungen ist auch gesetze zu
ändern um an eigentümer heranzukommen um
auch zu sehen wo es möglicherweise
geldwäsche im spiel wer hat quasi auch
unter falschen namen eigentum erworben
das war mir sehr wichtig und vor allen
dingen auch dem bundeskriminalamt die
seit jahren so eine meinung haben
wollten und ich bin froh dass uns das
jetzt gelungen ist bei mir gibt es
keinen rabatt ich will die bekämpfung
kleinkriminalität einen meiner schwester
das ging ganz gut sie haben gar nicht
die frage beantwortet wer nämlich die
villa ersteigert hat das ist nämlich
ausgerechnet der sohn von arafat abou
chaker der ist 21 und hat 7,1 millionen
euro einfach mal so auf den tisch gelegt
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
ich hatte mit 21 keine 7,1 millionen
euro und ich glaube die allermeisten
deutschen sehen ja willen immer nur von
außen akon ackern am ende reicht auch zu
was tollem das reihenhäuschen die
wohnung aber die villen sehen doch die
meisten deutschen nur von außen und
können sie da eigentlich verstehen dass
die deutschen sagen der ehrliche ist in
diesem land mittlerweile der dumme also
wie gesagt ich kenne willen auch nur von
außen wie sie es auch beschrieben haben
und deswegen macht es mir ja so viel
sorge was da passiert und deswegen ist
es für mich so wichtig die kleinen
kriminalität zu bekämpfen zu gucken wo
sind illegale gelder weil mit 21 ist
jedoch sehr unwahrscheinlich dass das
eben auch geld es wasser selbst verdient
hat
einfach zugucken wie kommen wir da ran
deswegen wie gesagt der verweis auf die
neue gesetz wirkung dass das bka andere
zugriffsrechte hat also sie selber
glauben auch nicht dass der 21-jährige
der ja aus einer familie kommt wo die
mit zuhälterei in verbindung gebracht
wird mit diebstahl mit
schutzgelderpressung mit
urkundenfälschung mit raubüberfall sie
glauben auch nicht dass dieser
21-jährige ehrlich an die 7,1 millionen
gekommen ist also mir stets natürlich
gern dinge zu beurteilen ohne
rechtsstaatliche verfahren zu haben da
bin ich als bundesinnenministerium
natürlich immer an recht und gesetz
gebunden aber wenn wir den verdacht
haben und wir kriegen so was mit oder
wie jetzt messerstechereien auf offener
straße oder kriminalität die einfach vor
anderen stattfindet wo früher drauf
wurde so nacht wurde wir klären das
unter uns nein wir leben einem
rechtsstaat da muss der rechtsstaat hart
durchgreifen das lassen wir nicht zu
kündigen sie hier gerade ermittlungen in
diesem fall an weil bislang ist da ja
nichts passiert wird jetzt ermittelt
woher der 21-jährige die 7,4 millionen
hat also wenn es anhaltspunkte dafür
gibt dann wird auch ermittelt ich kann
mich natürlich nicht in landes
angelegenheiten der polizei einmischen
das mache ich nicht es gibt einen
föderalismus
das bka ist in unserem bereichen tätig
wurde ermittelt dass veganer jetzt gehen
die leute kann ihn zu einzelnen
ermittlungsverfahren jetzt hier nicht
sagen okay gut sie haben gerade selber
schon über messerstechereien gesprochen
wissen sie wie viele es in den letzten
zwei jahren todesopfer bei
messerstechereien gegeben hat sie in das
al aini gerade präsenten präsident des
mediziners sind einige das weiß ich
natürlich weil ich die
kriminalitätsstatistik mit dem bka chef
vorgestellt habe wo wir auf die gesamt
kriminalitätsentwicklung auch hinweisen
und da sehe ich natürlich eine zunahme
der gewalttaten auf das in essen über 60
jahre was kann man dagegen tun also
vielleicht schauen wir auch noch mal
ganz kurz in den alltag im freibad in
deutschland rein wenn wir da mal eben
kurz ins video gucken könnten das sind
auch beeindruckende szenen von einem
deutschen alltag würde mich
interessieren was sie dazu sagen
können wir das einmal ganz kurz
einspielen
[Musik]
doch das reicht auch schon einen
eindruck zu bekommen
frau innenministerin was ist das was wir
da sehen wie würden sie diese szenen
beschreiben es ist sieht nach einer
schlägerei aus in einem freibad
für mich ist wichtig dass der
rechtsstaat durchgreift dass es genügend
ausreichend personal vor ort gibt damit
so etwas nicht passiert als die familien
mit kindern müssen ja unbeschwert oder
auch jugendliche ins schwimmbad gehen
können in deutschland das ist ja etwas
was mich tag für tag umtreibt auch in
der realität bekämpfung dort natürlich
vorzugehen so dass die menschen sicher
leben das ist mein job
haben wir zu sorgen gemeinsam mit den
landes- und dass das klingt sehr gut
frau verse aber es sind szenen die wir
jetzt aus diesem sommer zeigen und wir
haben dann auch im bild groß darüber
berichtet und da haben wir ganz viel
auch zuschriften bekommen dass es
eigentlich in den freibädern jeden tag
so zugeht da ist doch schon was aus den
fugen geraten oder das darf natürlich
nicht passieren ich will es noch mal
sagen da muss hinreichend polizeipräsenz
dann hin wenn es im moment in den
freibädern so ein problem ist ich werde
das auch noch mal in der
innenministerkonferenz ansprechen bei
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen
innenministern aus den ländern dass wir
da offensichtlich polizei präsenz
verstärken müssen wir müssen natürlich
schauen in welcher zeit leben wir moment
was bedrückt die menschen derzeit aber
es muss klar sein dass wir in einem
demokratischen staat oder rechtsstaat im
fortschritt ist das wäre so was
natürlich nicht zulasse würden sie sagen
dass das gewollt ist die primär aus
migrantischen milieus kommt ja was sie
gerade gesehen haben auch also gleich
was ich gerade gesehen hab ja das kann
man auch so benennen weil es zu sehen
war da sagen jetzt sie überall so ist
bei sagen extra das kann man auch so
benennen finden sie dass wir uns in
deutschland schwer damit tun gerade
gewalt aus migrantischen milieus auch
als solche zu bekennen also ich tue mir
nicht schwer damit ich glaube wir leben
in einem staat indem man dinge auch
benennen kann klar benennt ich werde
auch von kleinkriminalität ich glaube
ist es wichtig dass auch zu tun damit
die menschen auch sehen dass wir die
dinge ernst nehmen dass wir dinge
benennen und uns nicht wegducken sie
haben in ihrem ressort ganz viele
unterschiedliche probleme in der
gesellschaft was ist das größte na ja
wir haben
viele bereiche die uns im moment sorgen
machen islamistischer terrorismus ist
beispielsweise etwas wo wir uns sehr
stark darum kümmern wir haben ja gerade
vor anderthalb wochen den furchtbaren
islamistischen anschlag terroranschlag
in oslo gehabt also diese bedrohung ist
sehr präsent da kümmern wir uns sehr
stark darum präventiv aber auch mit
aller härte des rechtsstaates wir haben
ganz viele verfahren im moment laufen in
deutschland auch gegen mutmaßliche
islamisten aber frau fässer
entschuldigen sie dass ich sie da
unterbreche von ihnen selbst ihr eigenes
büro oder sie selber haben erst am 16
juni in foto verbreitet auf dem sie zu
sehen waren und da hatten sie
schülerinnen und schüler zu gast ich
glaube im ministerium wenn ich das
richtig im kopf habe und da hat man dann
gesehen dass sie im hinteren teil des
bildes gleich mehrere schüler zeichnen
gemacht haben die zu den grauen wölfen
gehören also zu einer extremistisch
eingestuften organisation türkischen
organisation und auch andere
extremistische zeichen gemacht haben da
haben sie ja eigentlich die
verfassungsfeinde in ihr eigenes haus
eingeladen also es sind verfassung
schülerinnen und schüler aus
verschiedenen schulen aus ganz
deutschland gewesen die wir eingeladen
hatten an einem projekt teilzunehmen das
haben sie gemacht als sie das foto das
als wir das hinterher gesehen haben
haben es ja sofort rausgenommen das
hatte konsequenzen die schülerinnen und
schüler die diese zeichen gezeigt haben
haben auch ihr diplom verloren das
akzeptieren wir in keinen fall sie haben
es angesprochen sie dass das hilft dann
das diplom der verlieren dann das diplom
der warum hat man die überhaupt erst
ausgewählt wie kann das sein dass im
bundesinnenministerium diese zeichen
gezeigt werden und dann ist die
konsequenz dass die irgendwie ihr diplom
verlieren das den würde ich jetzt mal
sagen den sah man ja auch ein bisschen
anders die die sache nicht ernst
genommen haben sind die dann bestraft
wenn man denen das wegnimmt also wir
wählen nicht aus wir haben eine
zusammenarbeit mit einem träger der
schulen aus wählt der wählt nicht aus
innerhalb der schule wer darf teilnehmen
wir nicht sondern es dass der ganze
klassen verbunden und wichtig ist ja
dass wir bei der gelegenheit jetzt auch
darauf hinweisen ja es sind verbotene
symbole es sind symbole von klar
rechtsextremistischen organisationen wie
den grauen wölfen die wir natürlich als
haus auch sehr stark bekämpfen und zwar
natürlich jetzt eine gelegenheit um auch
mal wieder darauf hinzuweisen aber es
klar sowas darf nicht passieren
trotzdem ist es passiert und ihr büro
das foto auch noch selber verbreitet
haben sie da eigentlich konsequenzen
gezogen das muss doch noch mitarbeiter
oder eine mitarbeiterin oder vielleicht
tatsächlich auch ihn selbst auffallen
mensch da sind aber welche in der
letzten reihe die machen verbotene
zeichen oder tatsächlich ein verbot 50
schülerinnen und schülern gestanden und
vorne das ja konnte mir nicht gefallen
dass das konsequenzen hat das völlig
klar es gibt jetzt sechs augen prinzip
und das wird natürlich jetzt auch mit
den fachabteilungen über fotos 3
angeschaut sie äußern sich ganz oft auf
twitter frau reese und da haben sie vor
kurzem geschrieben wir müssen den
begriff heimat positiv umdeuten dann
ging der satz noch ein bisschen weiter
aber das darf man schon so zitieren das
ist der zusammenhängen dass hat warum
müssen wir den begriff heimat umdeuten
ich finde dass manche menschen heimat
mit einem negativen begriff belegen das
finde ich sehr schade weil für viele
menschen ist heimat etwas sehr
wertvolles etwas total wichtiges und
wird auch unterschiedlich definiert die
einen definieren ist mit ihrer familie
wo die sind andere definieren das an
einem ort das gibt menschen die gerne
was ich noch bayern in die berge fahren
das ist für sie heimat verlieren daher
für mich ist die heimat dort wo meine
familie ist mein mann mein sohn das ist
für mich heimat wenn die jetzt in
frankfurt wohnen ist es dort wenn sie
jetzt hier in berlin sind ist es hier
ich würde das immer an meine familie
aber da müssen wir den begriff
vielleicht gar nicht umdeuten und neu
definieren naja umdeuten im sinne von
positiv belegen mich stört dass manche
menschen den begriff heimat noch immer
irgendwie negativ oder konservativ oder
altbacken oder wie auch immer bewerten
ich will ihn positiv bewerten jeder soll
heimat darunter verstehen was er
darunter versteht es positiv belegen und
das ist ein sehr offener vielfältiger
begriff so wie jeder sich selber heimat
definiert für viele ist es ein ort das
ist auch schön und für andere ist es
eben da wo familie oder freunden oder
die verlobte die ehefrau ist und
deswegen mir ging es darum es positiv zu
belegen frau innenministerin wir haben
schon über die größten probleme mit
denen sie sich in ihrer arbeit befassen
müssen gesprochen sie hatten als erstes
den islamismus genannt sie schreiben
auch sehr viel über den
rechtsextremismus was ich wahnsinnig wir
also was ich persönlich wahnsinnig
wichtig finde vor kurzem sind bilder
aufgetaucht eine junge polizistin auch
die war eine ganz besondere polizistin
wurde nämlich praktisch von den behörden
ins schaufenster gestellt bei instagram
um für den polizeiberuf zu werben jetzt
stellt sich heraus sie ist liiert mit
einem rechtsextremisten was geht ihnen
da durch den kopf er ist schrecklich
weil natürlich gerade in den behörden
diejenigen die den staat vertreten
natürlich nicht rechtsextremistisch sein
dürfen oder auch linksextremistisch auf
jeden fall müssen die ein besonderer art
und weise unsere demokratische
grundordnung vertreten deswegen bin ich
da so besonders streng an die
anforderungen der mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter deswegen habe ich in meinem
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus den
ich sehr früh vorgelegt hat mit
konkreten maßnahmen auch gesagt dass wir
verfassungsfeinde wenn wir sie in
unseren reihen haben auch möglichst
schnell aus den reihen entfernen können
okay
ich habe noch ein anderes thema das mich
eben so umtreibt wieder
rechtsextremismus es ist der
antisemitismus immer besser in diesem
jahr ist es passiert das in kassel ein
großes bild enthüllt wurde und auch
gleich noch mehrere bilder in nämlich
bei der großen kunstveranstaltung
documenta diese bilder waren ganz
glasklar ich denke da müssen wir nicht
darüber diskutieren die waren ganz
glasklar antisemitisch ein jude war
abgebildet der als jude zu erkennen sein
sollte um war dann als schwein
verfremdet wie kann so etwas passieren
also für mich ist ganz klar
antisemitismus darf es nicht geben muss
ganz massiv bekämpft werden es gibt
leider viel zu viele fälle in
deutschland ich finde auch beschämend
dass man wenn man jüdischen glauben ist
morgens sein kind wenn man es in die
kindertagesstätte gibt dass sie das
unter polizeischutz machen das ist
furchtbar ist einer meiner wichtigsten
aufgaben antisemitismus zu bekämpfen ich
will das einfach noch mal klar sein das
was in kassel zu sehen war geht gar
nicht und welche freiheit hat auch da
seine grenzen wo andere menschen
beleidigt werden das war hier ganz klar
der fall deswegen war es gut dass ist
abgehängt wurde es wurde abgehängt aber
frau roth kulturstaatsministerin ist
weiterhin im amt die chefin der
dokumentarist weiterhin immer hand
laufen wir nicht gefahr dass wir einen
zustand von dem wir immer geschworen
haben nie wieder nie wieder
antisemitismus schon gar nicht auf der
bekanntesten kunstveranstaltung dass wir
den hier zu lassen und im grunde
passiert danach nichts ich meine
abhängen ist ja das mindeste abhängen
ist in der tat das mindeste für so etwas
es ist ja im vorfeld zwar eine
interessante entwicklung drüber
diskutiert worden genau was kommt da was
kommt da nicht ich glaube es wäre für
alle die verantwortlichen wichtig
gewesen einmal vorher vielleicht drauf
zu schauen und zu gucken sind grenzen
überschritten weil bei mir gilt ganz
klar und das gilt für jegliche form von
antisemitismus das immer da wo grenzen
anderer wo die gefühle anderer verletzt
werden ist es eben nicht akzeptabel und
das war bei dem bild eindeutig der fall
und deswegen muss man jetzt gucken wie
man das auf arbeitet wer da wie welche
verantwortung dafür getragen hat ist ein
bisschen spät dran also das ganze ging
er über wochen eigentlich müsste
vielleicht die chefin längst
zurückgetreten sein oder frau roth aber
ist er gott sei dank so dass das bild
als es hang sehr schnell gottseidank
abgehängt wurde ich glaube dass es in
dem fall ja dass wichtige dass man auch
konsequent ist ich fühle mich da auch
sehr verletzt bei soja und dann ja ok
vor wer so eine letzte frage
diese woche ist auch das hat eine
besondere woche weil ein
kabinettskollege von ihnen heiratet was
schenken sie christian lindner zur
hochzeit und was wünschen sie ihm und
seiner künftigen ehefrau also ich
wünsche ihm in seiner ehefrau natürlich
alles erdenklich gute das sie vor allen
dingen glücklich miteinander werden dass
sie eine tolle zeit haben dass sie jetzt
erst mal eine schöne hochzeit auf sylt
verbringen und was ich ihm schenke
verrate ich hier noch nicht perfekt
vielen dank bregenz waren schönen abend
eine auch dankeschön
[Musik]